[Music]
I'm the one
all right so folks if you only knew who
just got a new job we can announce that
today phenomenal for him congratulations
congratulations is uh some call them
Anthony some call him Tony but you can
call him a new hire Reed at this new
company which will announce when he's
got the details
not up in here some people's careers are
just Recession Proof I'm I'm just
astonished well listen when you're the
goat you get stuff like that that
happened to you by the way we had a Alex
Jones on Saturday if you missed it uh
you were hiding somewhere now watching a
podcast he said something on Twitter a
clip of on Twitter about him and what
what he said about Trump could happen to
him the assassination stuff that's gone
viral we've got a lot of uh people
hitting us up but maybe we'll talk about
that today on the podcast a bunch of new
things going on with the economy uh
craziness with uh home number of sales
we have a stat that shows the least
affordable City to own a home if you
only could guess what the city is the
least affordable place to own a home in
which city moved up seven spots it's uh
it's pretty interesting would you be
surprised with that number Adam I don't
know about that City being number one
though maybe three maybe four but to be
number one least affordable I have some
thoughts on that yeah well it's not
actually breaking news yeah we'll we'll
cover that as well and then uh CNN is
for sale Jeff Zucker might buy it you
got the Fox News finally announces
reveals their new Prime Time roster uh
Legacy Media companies enter dark times
as failures Mount and Netflix rises
again there's no court documents reveals
more about Epstein's relationship with
JPMorgan Chase there's an article that
came out saying do you think you're rich
here's what Americans say we got some
thoughts there Tom's got some things to
talk about about what's going on right
now what home prices a couple stories
about woke uh here's one for you Blue
State School District won't let students
opt out of Pride lessons and if that
doesn't irritate you here's another one
for you student banned from walking at
graduation after boys or boys and girls
or girls comments so this kid said boys
are boys girls are girls she was not
able to walk across this kid was not
able to walk across the stage will
comment on that vivex got a good article
a couple things he said on Twitter which
we'll talk about in regards to same
topic box office analyst estimates
Disney loses
890 million dollars on their last eight
theatrical releases and a few other
stories we got a video of RFK doing
push-ups the guy looks like he's going
to run for Mr Universe
we got some proud boy stuff that I think
uh Vinnie wants to talk about but more
importantly before we get out into all
these stories couple things Fourth of
July is around the corner these hats
that many of you vets have been asking
about we worked on these hats so much to
make them perfect and give a couple
different options these future looks
bright hats for veterans or those who
love America are here one is is white on
the side that says future looks bright
the other one's got the white
valuetainment logo with the Bottom
future looks bright the other one is the
black vitamin Loco future looks bright
and the future looks bright on the
bottom and in gear that's the military
gear we got a bunch of stuff which has
flags on the side I can't wait for you
to see it it's going to be launched with
a video we did at a shooting range if
you want to be one the first to get the
update once we're launching this new
merch the merch drop text the word merch
to
310-340-1132 once again text award merge
310-340-11322 be one of the first to get
this sent over your way before it sells
out we're excited about and by the way
for anybody that makes purchase over 250
dollars we'll have your phone number I'm
a surprise FaceTime you I did this last
time every year man that's a lot of fun
when we do it maybe we'll do it together
as a crew and he purchase over 250 will
pick some of them surprise you guys with
a FaceTime call and no we'll have chat
again text award merch to
310-340-1132 these hats will sell out
ASAP let's get right into it okay so by
the way uh we talked about this on the
podcast with Alex Jones but I want to
get into the podcast a little bit more
with this topic here's what happened
over the weekend do you know what New
Station covered all the mess that's
going on with Biden right now
do you know what news do you know what
channels covered everything that's going
on with Biden right now with his son
with the questions not being answered
guess what new station covered
everything that's going on with Biden
not holding back the sun any of that
stuff MSNBC NBC CBS and ABC forget Fox
forget CNN but NBC ABC CBS what does
that tell you when those guys do that
what does it tell you I I think that's a
great question I was thinking about this
uh this morning I think now that they're
realizing and they timed the perfectly
Pat they're letting the stories of Biden
come out to letting everything come out
yeah so he slowly gets out gets out of
the way and their their front runner is
going to come in and I think it's going
to be Newsome that's what they're doing
they know he has no chance yeah they can
they can't hide the secret that much
longer you feel like I'm with you 100
and I know Adam and I have a different
read on this not in Conflict but we just
kind of reading the tea leaves on the
DNC differently but I think the DNC
highly impacts those top three
mainstream media and I and I've said you
know six months ago I said man remember
I used to comment that they're they're
taking dog off the leash let the DNC
kind of allowed them to say some things
about Biden some unflattering things
about
um uh you know uh
Kamala Harris not going to Taco Bell not
getting a run for the Border uh remember
you know I'll get to the Border
eventually uh do you happen to have
directions the and what's going on right
now I believe the networks have been
released because remember you can look
at all those things why do you think I
think they've been released because I
think there is a quiet movement in the
Democratic party that this needs to be
primaried that's I have felt that way
for a year because that's the only
outcome here Pat what is the outcome
it's either Biden goes alone and we're
all behind him salute all the DNC and
all the organization salute or they're
going to softly allow the the things to
happen to have an Open Primary so let me
let me ask this question how long how
long before
how long before we know Biden's not
going to be running as president how
long is it going to be 30 days 60 days
90 days six months what do you think
it's going to be I think it's
Thanksgiving because that puts you about
60 days before first primaries remember
first primaries happen right after the
beginning of the year so you don't think
it's going to happen for another five
months no I think yeah I I think it has
to happen by November okay I'm saying it
has to happen by Thanksgiving and if
backdoor
um a wrestling holds it off yeah it has
it'll have to reach ahead so somebody do
a year before the election well look if
there's one thing I learned from Alex
Jones what's the primary thing there's a
few things that I learned from Alex
Jones but the one thing is he's like
sometimes they're just telling the story
right in front of your face yeah you
don't need to go down the rabbit hole
which he's done multiple times
um but the story to me the main story
here is not speculative not predictions
not prognosticating it's that these Main
Legacy Media companies are actually
being journalists that's the main story
here they're not being activists they're
not telling one side of the story from
the mic please yeah
they're not being activists they're
actually being journalists that is the
story is that they're actually covering
what they're supposed to be covering and
kudos to that why though now if we want
to why because they're [__]
journalists no and they're remembering
that so why didn't now if you want to go
down the rabbit hole okay conspiracy
theory-wise well they're trying to
remove Biden which I can understand that
but there hasn't been any indications
that that's still actually happening
what you're saying if you're gonna go
down the the Gavin Newsom rabbit hole
which is fine he was just battling
one-on-one where he [__] owned Sean
Hannity on his own show uh he's done
nothing but support Biden to his face
they were just together a week ago so
yes I do believe that Gavin Newsom would
be a way more attractive candidate than
Biden who doesn't think that despite all
of
you know
Gavin newsom's issues what did you just
say the last one minute okay honestly
like what did you just say so you just
said okay so you just said you you said
what you're saying that the journalists
are actually doing their job and they're
covering these journalists don't do
their jobs okay
no no we've but but no no Adam when
somebody hasn't been doing their jobs
for the last 10 years suddenly starts
doing their job it's not because
suddenly they got inspired to say let's
become journalists today no there has to
be a motive why on suddenly they became
journalists all aligned simultaneously
together if when the first uh Durham
report came out what did ABC CBS and NBC
cover nothing they not they didn't talk
about it during report why not they
didn't do journalism are they going to
start doing that as well every time a
lot of this but now suddenly you're all
bashing Biden simultaneously we're
Kareem Jean-Pierre am I saying the name
correctly yeah she's standing like no
and then Kirby has to come and save her
no one didn't have to walk off no what
is starting to happen right now as the
Dems are sitting there saying lowest
approval rating this is not a conspiracy
theory this is called an opinion podcast
where we give our thoughts that we're
not a professional journalist that we
went to Columbia University and this is
what we do no we're talking and we're
chatting and we're like similar to some
American people that are saying I'm
thinking that as well I see that as well
the only reason this trend all of a
sudden flipped in my opinion not a
conspiracy not my conspiracy in my
opinion is
lowest approval rating
they're starting to realize like by the
way you know I'll give I'll give it to
you from the perspective that'll make
sense to you you know some of your
friends that are Trump guys the ones
that I'm not talking about the guys
that'll never change don't talk don't
think about those guys you know the guys
that supported Trump because they like
his policies but then gradually stuff
that's coming up with indictment the
recording the this to that they're like
I don't know man I think I have to kind
of distance myself because to me is I
can go to Santa's because it's pretty
much the same thing I'm getting minus
all the drama you know those guys the
Democrat people of those guys are
showing up and they're saying yeah you
know what I'm not gonna do Biden because
I know what he's doing all this other
stuff like all the stuff that's coming
out on him right now dude I'm getting
off of it and I'm going to Newsom and
realistically realistically I think this
thing can go super fast very quickly
because
okay so on Fox News would you say would
you say Brett Bear is pro-trump
I would say that he's as close to being
a real journalist as it gets on Fox news
but do you think if he has a choice just
the speculation not that we know we're
playing a game here do you think he what
percentage do you think he's DeSantis
versus Trump oh okay all right well to
answer that was he more Trump or Biden
he's more Trump is he more DeSantis or
Trump he's more descent okay perfect I
agree with that so all I'm saying right
now is there is a audience that actually
likes spread bear and it's like man I
love what you're doing right yeah your
dinos but but but no no but there's also
an audience that likes what Jake tappers
do from the conservative side to say at
least Jake was so Democrats like Brett
Bear some Republicans like Jake tappers
some of his work right moderates who do
their job so there's Republic I think
Democrats and Republicans are in the
same exact situation today
I think they're in the identical
situation today here's what it is Dems
and media
wants Newsome
but the 100 defense Biden as long as
it's against Trump
Republicans in media journalists not all
of them I'm not putting Tucker on some
of these guys in the camp most
Republican you know journalists they if
it's Trump against Biden they're going
Trump but if it's Trump against the
centers they want the centers
it's it's a very weird thing that just
happened this weekend when these guys
flipped on Biden that quickly ABC CBS
NBC you're not supposed to do that so
maybe when that typically happens I
guarantee you these guys that are higher
ups
uh uh uh these guys that are higher ups
deaf conversations with each other
because they'll went to the same schools
not in a dark way in a way that's
naturally going to be happening but you
know what the conversations are like
look you know I just talked to me yeah I
know she told me she wants to know
something yeah did you hear right yeah
yeah I know the people at CBS they want
they want news and they already have the
conversation so how's it going to happen
I don't know man I'm hearing different
things you know I'm hearing Biden's
going to come out and talk about the
fact that his health is not good and
once they've spent time with his
grandkids you know you think it's going
to be ugly like they're going to oust
them no I think there's been meetings to
say look we can do this the nice way or
the ugly way do you want to protect your
legacy why don't we do it a nice way you
step away we'll make a movie about you
we'll make a documentary on every single
channel CBS ABC this for the unifier
president that will leave that as your
legacy we'll get a big book deal for you
for Simon and Schuster but only if you
do it the nice way do I think those
steps of conversation happen five ten
percent I think it could happen so all
I'm saying is they're telling this guy
brother it's been good go kick it yeah
it's time to move on that's all I'm
saying I'll just give one quick I'm on
that page uh you're you're right
so that I'm not going to disagree with
you the only difference is
you said that they're kind of what's
happening the fracturing in the
Democratic side is always is already
happening in the Republican side what
I'm also saying is I'm looking at the
facts in front of my face and I'm taking
the words from the candidate's mouth and
Gavin Newsom has said nothing and done
nothing to indicate that now where do I
agree with you yes of course no
Democrats are excited about by zero it's
not a thing they just didn't want Trump
that's the whole reason that he was
elected the difference is on the
Republican side how many candidates have
already announced their candidacy you
got the Santas you got Chris Christie
you've got Nikki Haley you've got Tim
Scott you've got Vivek so meaning like
I'm just looking at the information in
front of my face and there's infighting
within the GOP straight up
on the surface they're coalescing around
Biden now I think that's a horrible move
from a strategy standpoint I don't think
that that guy's a winning candidate
again but there's nothing that I've seen
physically come out of Gavin newsom's
face uh to say that he's running against
it I actually think but and by the way
the whole thing about you know what Alex
Jones said sometimes you just have to
look at it's right in front of your face
I don't think he meant what you think he
meant uh I think what Alex Jones is
saying that sometimes they will do it
boldly in front of your face thinking
you won't catch it yeah I think that's
what he means by it I don't think it's
just take the facts for what they're
saying no I don't trust what Newsome's
going to be saying to be honest with you
new the best way for Newsome to Ken
campaign for 2024 is by going around
talking about how amazing Biden is you
know why the the reason why you campaign
that way is because you're automatically
getting the to say what a freaking guy
man did you notice what he was doing up
until Biden decided to step out the guy
had his back what a loyal guy I value
loyalty unlike the scientist because
he's playing the game of royalty yeah he
knows the Dems are gonna say look unlike
the scientists whether you like Trump or
not he wasn't loyal to Trump look how
loyal Newsome is being to Biden these
guys are brilliant on what they're doing
he's being a flag the move that Newsome
is making is so freaking brilliant to
show himself as a loyalty to the party
and Trump is pinning the sentence as the
one that's not loyal to the party
because the same because Newsom in my
opinion my opinion knew some things the
sentence is going to be the candidate
because he thinks Trump's going to drop
out it's a gamble it's a very big gamble
because the chance of this happened is
less than five percent that Trump's
gonna drop out
from the race because they're eventually
going to get him on some of these
recording that's too late and by the way
I also think a part of the sentences
Camp the strategy they're playing behind
closers are like guys it's just a matter
of time before you discuss upon just a
matter of time before they get him just
a matter of time if you don't need to be
number one right now you don't need to
be number one right now the moment he's
out you will bump to 75 because there's
no Trump yeah that's I think that's
problematic you know what you know what
they call that I almost agree you know
what they call that what's in sports
they're playing prevent defense of
course homeboy Ron DeSantis our friend
here in Florida needs to go on the
offensive because what happens when
you're playing pre-vet defense and
you're expecting the other team not to
put up points and score on you what
happens boom backdoor touchdown trumps
the candidate so if you want to just
kind of play it safe and not go against
Trump and not really put pedal to metal
and go on podcasts and really put your
name out there Trump's going to gallon
DeSantis was
200 yards away from my house yesterday
when last night last night did he text
you nope it's not no him and I are not
did he DM you no no it's not nobody I'm
not saying that message to you it's
unfortunate what I'm saying to you is
he's in town he is out here doing what
he's doing uh at a guy's house was an
absolute stud of a guy one mission who
it is but uh he was there last night so
but but for me all I'm saying is with
all of this stuff that's going on
um
politics is strategy man and it's it
there's a part of this that is such a
dark you know you have to have an itch
for this game like you you have to be a
little bit mentally off
to want to be part of this game because
it's so freaking weird dirty strange
dark but also at the same time you know
but Plato I think said it he says those
who believe it's foolish
those who believe it's foolish to study
politics will be governed by fools who
do wow I think we're at a point right
now where we we can't be foolish what's
his name from uh what movie is it it's
chess it ain't Checkers uh training day
and you said why why ABC why am I said
why all the mainstream right now are
reporting like they're finally doing the
report that you're talking about they
have no choice Pat because this is a
this was last year Twitter was on we
have to we have to give a kudos to uh
Elon Musk if this was happening last
year bro the FBI was working with and at
Twitter suppressing every single story
that you're hearing so shout out to Elon
Musk because now they have no other
choice you have to report it because we
are listening to it in real time no
sensor raw as hell right in our face and
I think we own Elon Musk the fact that
now they have to because FBI is not
chilling at Twitter which they were so
say nope put that down nope not this
story not the hunter laptop story they
have no choice bro and it's all
accountability is weird that I'm
interested in what you think here
zero to 100 private private poll among
um uh Senators Congressman Democratic
Leadership private poll nobody knows
what is Biden's
he has a vote right now what is he at
private poll these folks so what are the
options Biden you know do they support
Biden as the candidate
private poll no one gets to know what's
the reality that comes out there
Senators 50 Senators you're saying who
who's there all of them forget about
party line vote I think
look I think they're all saying yeah man
I think no no no that's what I'm saying
we got to publicly support this guy but
there's no way
no I think low-key it's like 30 40
exactly so 70 would like to see it shift
yeah I don't know okay you know in my
opinion yeah I would say 100 I'd like to
see it shift sure I don't think he's an
attractive candidate I don't think he's
a strong leader I don't think he's the
man unfortunately that's what we're left
with so let me go one more step
odds one to a hundred that you think
there's real stuff here on the
international bribes
on the international with Hunter Hunter
I think they gotta look there's zero
smoke there's fire it's 100 it's it's
100 okay 50. I would say 100 there's no
don't I know you'll never ever hear me
say a hundred percent I will I win I'm
not trying to get you you're never gonna
hear me say 100 so because let me know
why don't you just answer the question
it's a basically go through the series
of questions we're already done in the
scope
so okay so 70 you would say I really
don't want them to run and or there's
smoke there's fire what is that 55 I
said 50 50. yeah 55th so more than 50
okay so fact January 15th is Iowa caucus
facts 60 days ahead of that these the uh
DNC releases money to bona fide primary
candidates so that is your deadline of
deadlines I mean they don't want to be
doing it there they want to be doing it
September 15th to give people before the
holidays time to do their campaigns okay
so we're really talking 90 days so now
I'll play conspiracy Joe listen you got
to do the health thing you got to give
us an out here and you need to step out
of this because we're gonna green light
we're not going to green light but
Republicans are going to push these
hearings and if there's really stuff
here you know it's gonna be hard to
support you in that and I believe that's
a lever point I believe there's enough
going on here that there's enough lever
points in the year of Investigation do
you see what I'm thinking that that they
can say you know you really need to do
this and I think Newsom that is I think
it's
greater than 50 probability that Newson
has already been said hey start
campaigning But be sure you do it from a
platform of support that you are a grand
Statesman for the Democratic party and
you're supporting the president so what
you're doing you're going on this Grand
support as the governor of the seventh
largest economy in the world and I
believe my heart when I go conspiracy
Pat that's what I think they've already
knew some is their candidate they're
waiting for a way to shift this they
only have really 90 days to do it to put
to give people the normal campaign
window from September to January and I I
think it's done and we're just waiting
for the lever and I think that when it's
too late meaning so so on September 15th
I think okay it comes too late because
right because if you were a candidate
Pat you're like hey man it's September
15th so you're supposed to give me 90
days of of DNC National money so then
saying Thanksgiving
is not right no I'm saying that is the
deadline of deadlines I'm like that is
the wall that is the red line I think
that's too late though Tom yeah I agree
more I think I think if they got to do
it I think if they got to do it they got
to do it right now because the Santa is
uh unlike I'm sorry uh Newsome unlike
the scientists will go out there and
we'll sit down with people he'll go I
believe that I believe I believe he will
go on podcasts I believe he'll go on
enemy territory I believe he'll go
anywhere I believe he'll go anywhere I
believe Newsom will go anywhere and be
able to hang and and not because his
argument's a better argument because he
knows how to handle the argument in a
way that's going to still give him the
favorability of seeing like he knows
what he's doing uh I think I think
Newsom needs more time but I think if
they do it in the next 30 60 days it's
plenty of time for Newsom to be a real
competitor by the way Vinnie we had a
conversation six months ago what did I
predict we both did we both said it and
the bet I think I want to check yo can
you check if the odds have changed it
was my a 1400 plus 1400 exactly Craig
Avenue we called it and you actually
were the first one pass when he was on
the lawn when Biden was on vacation or
falling down and what was the prediction
he's gonna be that has he missed it yeah
2500 yeah by the way can we check wait
is that still Vegas odds is this I like
checking Vegas let's take a bet is that
really Vegas odds right now I don't know
about this website because let's go to
Vegas
we're doing the BET today no go do the
same one that Adam always points to but
yeah do the Vegas one but Pat you were
the first one and then me and Adam
jumped on it when you said he was
walking on the White House lawn with his
shirt off there it is and it was a
presidential walk Gavin newsom's now
33-1 before let's do it Adam
thousand dollars yes a ten thousand
dollar bet will pay you 330 000 let's do
it a hundred thousand one thirty three
point three by the way it was Triple
that six months ago it was 60 what was
in 60 but we'll look at RFK 16. yeah by
the way can we we check our friend Joe
Biden's approval ratings you have 538 up
real quick
we're really going down this political
path today I love it check if you go to
the top there's usually
um yeah how popular is Joe Biden check
that
so the beginning of his candidacy or his
presidency he was close to 60 percent is
that what that says on the left 55
percent and then I believe in August uh
yeah a disapproval 53 was that say Rob
yeah 53 okay
I want to say during like September of
21 if you where did where does it
crisscross
August 30th of 2021 okay gotcha August
30th September 1st I wasn't far off now
where is it now if you go all the way to
the end
so disapproval is 53 and is that his
approval is 41 so what's the net uh
disapproved plus 11 plus 11. now go to
Trump by the way 53 is very significant
and here's why you have core Republicans
only about 39 40 right core Republicans
they all disapprove then you have nine
percent of the independence in the
greens they all disapprove that's only
49 which means that he's got four
percent erosion that is assuming 100 of
Republicans 100 of Independents so he
already has four to five percent erosion
among among Democrats to put it bluntly
would you agree that his numbers are
trash oh absolutely but I'm pointing out
that he's lost at least five points of
his court base
forget about Kamala nobody cares about
her go to um go her the same numbers as
Biden go to Trump she's the worst she's
the worst ranked vice president right
Pat he's in the worst ever ever
um all right what does that say it's a
14 where's the eye is that 14. go to the
red go to go to it now we don't need to
revisit six years 14.3 okay so
unfavorable 54 favorable 40 his numbers
are right next to bidens well so if
you're Biden you're it's a race to the
bottom it's like yeah I suck but this
guy sucks just as much as me let's see
how late it holds up now that's if you
trust polls that's if you've trust
what's going on that's if you trust
Quinnipiac and Pew and ABC but those are
the numbers that that trumps
favorability rating this goes back to my
point my point is Republicans and
Democrats are in the same exact
situation right now especially the ones
in in this world who think they know
everything they're in the same place
Republicans are like can we do something
with Ron Democrats are like can we do
something with uh Newsome okay but but
here's the part about politics that that
you gotta love this is why you love this
game if you love it Mama love
competition so to me anything about
competition that's unpredictable I
freaking love it third quarter two
minutes left you're up 28-3 uh what are
the chances you're already picking your
Super Bowl speech you know hey you know
well listen you know I want to give a
shout out to my mom she was there for me
in the corner when everything was going
on my wife you know my kids my this oh
[__] we lost to Tom Brady oh you know
we're Atlanta Falcons how the hell did
this happen you know well no he came
back and pulled it off again and beat
your ass because it's called competition
right all that stuff we can say we can't
look at all the polls all the stories we
can speculate we can say whatever we
want
um there there are a few people that I
will say that I love what they're doing
I'm gonna keep talking about these guys
I love what vivec is doing Vivek is
talking policies I love what RFK is
doing rfk's talking policies can you
show uh uh uh RFK real quick with him
doing the push-ups if you if you got
that video there with him doing look at
take a look at this guy 69 years old by
the way is he juicing that maybe he's on
trt but that body doesn't look like a
juice body
you know it's a big factor for that Pat
he's not taking any vaccines here's the
party you have to realize people think
like if you choose listen you choose you
still have to go to the gym four or five
times a week look at this guy yeah that
doesn't look like a juicer's body though
a juicer's body you know maybe trt maybe
some of that stuff but I don't know
about all the other stuff he's looking
good and he's got policies and he's you
know challenging people take a look at
this at first people thought this was a
spoof they didn't know it was him where
is this how much is this 45 for the bar
it's not a lot of weight he's inclining
he's inclining 105 right there for 115
right there that's not a lot of weight
115 is not a lot that looks like a 25
and a 10. unless if it's a 35 and a 10
definitely not a 45. the 45 is right
next to it looks more like a 25 and a
10. tell you what he is the most jacked
presidential candidate we've ever
especially in the Democratic Party Guys
69 years old he's doing
go to Dr Peter Hotes how amazingly good
happened
body type in body he's taking a booster
an example of who to follow in in hell
yeah look at that guy he's somebody who
take who who eats junk food all the time
and doesn't work
90 grams of sugar Perkins
here's the question pbd yeah how old is
this guy 63 or 64. the average American
let's go with me now the average
American who's in their 60s do they look
more like Peter Hotes of course or do
they look more like Aria what's your
point though that RFK is an anomaly and
he's taking care of himself oh no I I
don't he's actually in great shape he
doesn't need but all the other nonsense
but here's the question people who look
like hotels who turned into a hero RFQ
or Peter Hotes who should you model
after if you're in your 60s it's not
even a question it's not even a question
so the point is you ought to go work out
like yes RFK is not eat junk food in
your 60s like Peter hotez's but to each
his own I don't know many 60 something
year olds that look like RFK I know a
ton of 60 year olds it looks sloppy like
hotels yeah actually believe it or not
what what I will tell you about uh uh
people who take care of themselves
there's there's a lot of people that
look at uh uh uh hotels and say that's
an irresponsible way of living man you
ain't going to be doing anything good
with yourself living a long time living
like that this whole concept goes back
to the same thing I've been talking
about last few years America's biggest
problem the last eight years seven years
has been who they make a hero of yeah
the hero making machine is the biggest
problem in America with your kids a bad
parent doesn't know who they turn into
hero a great parent know who they turn
into a hero a great parent will say look
what she did did you see what she did
that's exactly what great leaders do did
you see what he did did you see what she
did they're painting a picture with her
Heroes today a hero is somebody who's a
male who lost to all other male
opponents but chooses to identify as a
female becomes a swimmer beats all the
women and we say what a hero yeah what a
hero What A Brave by the way right there
it's women 40 oh yeah by the way what a
brave girl right there now you got a
hero making machine probably DVD to to
add something that definitely looks real
what a hero
comes well we're all familiar with this
one but uh to add some validity to what
you're saying have you seen did you see
what Elon Musk tweeted about all the uh
generals of Health across the world and
how they look so ugly for the health
administrators whatever it was hilarious
the director of Health for all these
different countries they all look it's
the sloppiest group of sad people I've
ever seen yeah
running your health programs yeah can
you find that image it was so bad oh
Rachel Levine all all the health
officials of all the countries around
the world are the skin right no no this
was less than a week ago oh well he
tweets 50 times
a month to scroll down you know what you
know what is a you know what is a a by
the way if you can't find a show because
I know exactly what tweet is talking how
many days back are you right now by the
way what date are you on you're wrong
okay June 14 keep going a little bit see
if you find it it might have been that
parody account is that by the way that
Elon Musk parody account is that
somebody else don't worry about it's
probably a period account so Rob go to
go to uh the the video of The View on
what they said about what's going on
with Biden and Hunter Biden and the way
they sold it which is uh very very
interesting I want you to see this folks
and tell me tell me if this makes sense
go ahead the hunter Biden Story the
Scandal the this that it's also the
story of a Father's Love and Joe Biden
has never and will never give up on his
son son Hunter and we'll never treat him
less than that and so he is a father
first
okay well the audience Applause you know
that right after this like they go crazy
for that state didn't the view say that
about George Herbert Walker Bush and W
that it was a story of a father's oh
wait they didn't listen no no Tom and
I'm sorry Pat because he's taken away
from the message he's a father you're a
father sir you're missing the point it's
about fatherly love the hell with the
crack and the prostitutes and the big
guy in the bribes Tom it's father love
and I'm actually embarrassed that you
don't he's not actually feeling like how
we're feeling that it's about love Tom
yeah father love you know you know you
know when you see something like this
here's what you say you say okay fine
but like
are you really thinking everybody's dumb
they really do it's it's so so Trump is
no longer a father he's not a father so
Trump is not a man and Trump's kids
defending him is not the love of a son
for our father yeah it's not but it's
because it's true
in a sun relationship by the way she's
not wrong there is an element of it that
is a father and son but at this point of
the game The Father's probably sitting
there saying dude like can you stop
doing so much mess constantly the
favoritism you see here and the
hypocrisy is exposed and it's shown and
it's very easy it's not subtle it's in
your face this is when Alex Jones says
in your face this is in your face
nothing about this is like something
yeah oh this is this yeah and by the way
do you think that that's her opinion do
you think that's the what the production
I was just gonna say I think that's what
the producers yeah I think that's her
opinion well let's just talk a little
bit of producers because the producers
Anna Navarro she's from Miami she
actually used to live in my building
hates Trump of course do you think hates
Trump you think okay so there's nothing
she's gonna do to defend Trump by the
way she's a republican but she's one of
those Republicans that I don't know
she's not a liberal she's one of those
Republicans that crossed over in 2016
when and she just couldn't do the Trump
thing and she's been knocking him ever
since but the reality is this Anna
What a Sad cope that you're trying to do
right here this yes he is a father but
once your father is the president of the
United States it goes beyond fatherly
love this is a matter of national
security so the one thing that I will
give Trump for sure credit on is his
kids turned out way better than Biden's
kids uh I mean he did lose Bo you know
sad situation former veteran died of I
think brain cancer very sad but you
don't see Donald Trump Jr smoking crack
on the side of a highway some
prostitutes I mean Kim Guilfoyle I don't
know what she is but I'm not going to
call her prostitute but she's probably
yipped up on something but uh you
remember when Hillary was uh debating
Trump and they're like say
one nice thing about the other candidate
do you remember what Hillary said what
Hillary saying she said I actually want
to give him credit for being a good
father and raising your kids well so you
got to give Trump credit on that now
listen I don't know how this happens I
know that opiums and and drug addiction
is a sad situation in this country and I
completely empathize with those problems
but if you're the president United
States how does it even come down to the
fact that you let your son become a
[__] crackhead oh how does that even
happen you took him into meetings with
foreign dignity dude he was his bag man
but if you think about it not only is he
the dumbest crackhead think about of all
the cracks you've ever seen they're in
the street they died he is the luckiest
crackhead in the history of crackheads
think about it making money and Tom he's
Untouchable he could do like literally
he could kill somebody live on camera
and nothing would happen at all yes he
could they'd say something like he he
was on drug he was on drugs you did a
money laundering scheme in plain sight I
by putting him up there as an artist who
is suddenly getting half a million
dollars yeah
kindergarten grade paintings yeah that
was he sold him as nfts he's an artist
scam club like the rest of America no no
it's like Adam you're asking hey man
everybody's watching what am I supposed
to do here hang on Adam we got something
okay Adam this we're gonna do you're
gonna buy a painting I'm gonna what
you're gonna buy a painting it's
completely legal just go go to Gallery
buy the painting are you kidding me nope
by the painting and it's a very public
money laundering scheme you know you
know what is uh one thing about
leadership like one I would talk to my
guys and let's just say I'm run the
company and and the guys are being super
tough on the company
and let's just say during that season
I'm going through something whatever
could be kids Family Life Health
whatever
I I I don't respect people who use that
as a way to gain sympathy well you don't
know what I'm going through well you
don't know what I'm going through well
you don't know what I'm going through
listen totally get it what you're going
through I understand but guess what
nobody asked you to be the Silver
Company
and nobody asks you to be the president
of the country nobody asks you to do
that but if you become a position like
that you know what you're telling the
world and what you're telling the world
is I can't be held at the same standards
as you because I'm getting more
attention and love and accolades and
respect and Legacy than you so people
can't sit there and say poor Trump poor
Biden poor this no in history trust me
they're gonna forget about 99 of people
that say poor Trump poor Biden history
is not going to forget about Trump or
Biden history is going to write about
these two guys and they're going to
forget about
99.9999 of all the other people in
America or the world right what does
that mean it was again [__] about the
position you took you chose to be that
position that position comes with a lot
of Burden you know the whole picture
about presidents eight years later what
they look like how they age quickly yeah
you go to the Smithsonian they chose
Lincoln when you go from the to uh
you're like oh my God this guy said he
says he says being a president as the
greatest burden I ever took the greatest
burden it comes with it and it is what
nobody told you to have a kid having a
kid is a lot of Burt nobody told you to
start a business it's starting a
business nobody told you to be a
president it comes with it so yes as
much as we can sympathize it is not a
job for anybody okay we also would
happen to Obama I mean he went from
being a young vibrant guy to gray hair
and Biden in three years went from a old
crotchety guy who kind of had it
together to a absolute mess he is a bag
of potatoes out there let's go through a
couple stories here let's go to a couple
stories here let's go to a couple
stories okay so uh do you think you're
rich here's what Americans say about you
being rich uh according to the 2023
modern wealth survey by Charles Schwab
Americans believe it takes 2.2 million
dollars to be considered wealthy but
those who feel wealthy today have an
average net worth of 560 000 it's pretty
interesting that's a you know small
amount the survey reveals that 62
percent of Americans prioritize healthy
relationships as a key indicator of
wealth while 70 believe wealth is more
about not having to stress over money
social media impacts wealth perceptions
about with 47 percent of Americans
saying being able to afford a lifestyle
comparable to their friends makes them
feel wealthy additionally 37 percent
compared their lifestyle to what family
and friends share on social media and 34
make purchase decisions based on what
they see on social media interesting
Adam thoughts well you know how big he
used to say Mo Money Mo Problems he had
that one wrong let me tell you something
uh Kanye I think had it uh said uh way
better he said having money isn't
everything but not having it is
um let me tell you something when you
have money in your life
all the little things all the little
problems all the little annoyances oh
flat tire oh traffic ticket oh monthly
rent do whatever none of those issues
matter any point and then what happens
is if you don't do what these other
people are doing and basically just keep
up with the Joneses and just follow what
people uh are buying on social media or
what people are doing what family and
friends and you you know are doing uh
that you're basically trying to keep up
with you can actually help the ones
around you and I think that's what I I
liked about this relationship is they're
prioritizing healthy relationships
um in their life to basically help the
people around you and I think that's
something that that you even you abide
by I see what you do with family friends
vacations parties I think that's what
the essence of life is when you have
money is empowering the people around
you like I just took my mom to Israel
cost me a good amount of money to go out
and travel but like that was great a
great investment in my time
um I I constantly help out friends that
are in need remember my buddy that we
went to dinner with that one time uh
with the basketball player at The Yard
House his kids becoming a great
basketball player he's like listen I'm
running low on funds like I want to take
them to
travel this summer and Basketball Camp
can I get a loan I'm like I got you bro
this is for your kid so that's what I
found when since I have money now and I
think that that I have like Financial
Freedom the best return on investment is
a investing in myself B helping the
people around me and then lastly buying
things that I think
um you know are nice and they're fun but
the last point that I'll say is this you
know they say the comparison is the
thief of Joy
um don't compare yourself to what other
people have what you should do is
compare yourself to where you were two
years ago five years ago ten years ago
and that should be the barometer for
your wealth
um
it really also comes down to age so for
instance if you're 40 don't compare
yourself to a 60 year old if you're 20
don't compare yourself to a 40 year old
so like look at pbd let's let's use them
as an example
judge yourself on where you were five
years ago ten years ago clearly you've
done well but don't compare yourself to
let's say Grant Cardone he's 65 years
old I didn't realize how old that guy
was I Googled it the other day homie 65.
now allegedly he's worth a half a
billion dollars or a billion I shouldn't
compare myself to Grant Cardone is that
what you just said I'm saying that by
the time you're 65. have you ever heard
me talk about Grant Cardinals zero ever
not weird I'm embarrassing this guy the
reason that I'm doing this before the
reason that I'm doing it is because he's
20 years older but but that's a very
terrible analogy because I've never
compared myself to Grand car I'm not I'm
not saying that you find the point
you're making I understand what you're
saying here right now but that was kind
of weird for you to say uh uh I'm just
saying I'm just saying he's way older
than you so you shouldn't compare
yourself to a Warren Buffett and I think
he's killing it in ways that for him to
be in in the physical shape that he is
and doing what he's doing you're making
a point about don't compare yourself to
other people in different places uh I do
believe in having positive peer pressure
around you to make you step up and
challenge yourself as much as possible I
think you need to be around an
environment here's what happens with
positive peer pressure
in a positive peer pressure one of two
things happens unfortunately I've seen
this in the last 20 something years
one either you cave and you quit and you
go to a more safer environment where it
doesn't give you the kind of pressure
that you're not giving your best or you
wake up one day and you're like damn
look who I've turned into very
impressive who I am today it's a it's a
it's a necessary thing to do to have
positive peer pressure around you but
the part where I said I can't believe
that's uh that's not a lot of money
wasn't a 2.2 million for me was the uh
what do you call it the 560 thousand
dollars yeah what do you say it said it
said what about 500 it says Those Who
feel wealthy today have an average net
worth of 560 000
560 000 is not a lot of money today it's
just not a lot of money today uh uh deep
and also it has to do with your age but
it's not a lot of money today when
you're looking at retirement close range
things like that so I don't know what
the age of this is anyways that's going
to the next story I want to go into the
next story with economy on Tom Tom let's
look at
um let's look at a papa papa
okay here we go number of U.S home sales
plunges to lowest level since 2012.
number of U.S home plunges to the lowest
level since 2012.
um so number of homes available for
selling units are made to announce a
fill by with 7.1 percent
previous year the first annual declines
since April of 2020 to reducing
availability to its lowest level since
2012 Redfin which reported the data
States nearly every homeowner with a
mortgage has an interest rate below six
percent meaning many are opting to stay
put because selling and buying a new
home uh would mean taking on a higher
monthly mortgage payment housing
affordability continues to be a major
concern with the median price of an
existing single-family home rising from
300 000 in 2020 to 393 thousand dollars
in April of 2023. this has caused the
mortgage payment as a percentage of
increase to jump 14.7 percent to twenty
six percent let me read that one more
time this has caused the mortgage
payment as a percentage of income to
jump from 14.7 percent of your income to
26 percent of your income which by the
way that's always what I go to when
these Realtors and mortgage officers are
like well let me tell you you know your
home prices are this and no if
affordability is something you have to
be thinking about and and Tom the guy
that gave us a report at the elite
Mastermind that we had the report that
he gave Vinnie in 2021 realtors in
California Brokers realtors in
California made 18 billion dollars in
Commissions in 2021. 18 billion 18
billion dollars in commissions that
dropped to nine billion the following
year okay nine billion dollars of the
following years how much commission
they've made which means there's not a
lot of inventory to sell the prices may
be held up but there's not enough
inventory to sell Tom when you see the
story what do you think about well what
I think about is on its face that's
exactly what we're saying and what this
gentleman pointed out and some
information out that I was digging in
um you know a year ago I thought
interest rates could get to 10 I
remember I said it on this podcast
saying they got up to seven seven and a
half percent and they've they've kind of
mellowed a little bit but it's a
sustained it's not just a spike it's not
coming back down and the interest rate
is exactly what is driving this that if
if I was to some let's say I had to move
from Nashville and I had to move to you
know uh Plantation
um I look at it and say well if I sell
my house in Nashville and then buy a
house in Plantation you know seven
percent interest rates I'm screwed so
you know what people are doing I will
lease the house with this three percent
um interest rate in Nashville and I'm
just gonna go lease a house in South
Florida because I probably even if I
sold in Nashville I probably wouldn't be
able to afford to buy the house so
what's happening is the supply is stuck
this is called the stuck supply problem
where people even if their job forces
them to move their Airbnb or they're
keeping their house in the previous
Market because as a low interest rate
and they want to preserve that interest
rate by the way it's also got property
tax based on the purchase value way back
when and if they bought that house in
Florida they're going to be buying at a
higher purchase price so their property
tax is going to be up in addition to the
um actual payment so we have a supply
problem that is keeping prices High and
the high mortgage rates is causing the
supply to be low because no one wants to
sell their houses
I'll flip it for you Pat can we go to
San Francisco just one second home
prices are down 17 in San Francisco why
is that I'll tell you why because Supply
is coming up why is Supply coming up
because people are leaving and why are
people leaving because of the jobs in
the city and the policies in San
Francisco so when you have intervening
factors in San Francisco that are
causing people to actually say you know
what I am selling and I am leaving the
supply comes up and the prices come down
despite the mortgages so there's a I
won't dive into it but there's a blue
city mayor you know case study to be
done here of what they've done that's
causing people to actually sell at this
time no matter what and so prices are
coming down in San Francisco but on a
market level
the supply is going to remain stuck for
a little while here because the FED is
saying uh in their last uh report they
may raise a little bit at the end of
July like another quarter point but they
don't see a a steady reduction in rates
for two years I'll add one thing to that
I mean we all know in basic economics
the law of supply and demand it's the
number one thing you should understand
but it's hard to gauge that just looking
at it like what's the supply what's the
man but what you can gauge if you're an
average person out there
is this home or this car or this asset
is it cheap or is it expensive and
that's something that you could eyeball
and be like all right yeah I can afford
that that sounds like a good deal or
holy [__] how the hell am I gonna afford
something like this so do that it's hard
for you to eyeball supply and demand
like in San Francisco but it's very easy
for the average person
uh to understand whether you're getting
a good deal on something or whether
you're paying an arm and a leg and these
days people completely understand that
they're paying an arm and a leg for
homes out there because the supply is
not exactly where it it could be or it's
not very high and
um prices are
unbelievably high and this is what we've
said for a while so people are asking
well what do I do right now what's in it
for me I'll tell you what's in it for
you it's in it for you if you're in a
market that is that is
maintained its covid pop on pricing and
you don't see it coming down now it's
not the time to buy a house Now's the
Time is to lease as if as efficiently as
you can and save your money if you're
fortunate to be in a market where maybe
prices are coming back down a little bit
now I sound like sauce because he's
right and the reason I sound like sauce
is because on this point Adam is 100
right save that it's okay to rent it's
okay to save that money and wait for a
good time to buy
yeah and Adam that being said after
everything from listening from you and
listening to Pat and listen to what you
said about your friend I feel
comfortable asking if I could borrow 25
000 sure no problem thanks Adam I
appreciate it you know you know when you
when you you say something about
17 uh prices down in San Francisco more
than 330 billion dollars of equity lost
in San Francisco that's a lot of money
330 billion dollars in value lost in San
Francisco right okay this is the epoch
Times article if you want to read it you
can go look at the article further but
you know you you see this and you say
bad policies have consequences did you
know Tom
what city in America across the board if
you look at income
five to ten thousand dollar income range
then ten to twenty thousand dollar
cohort twenty to Thirty forty to fifty
50 to 60 all the way down to you know to
200 000 plus which city has the most 200
000 plus earners In America which city
do you know because we talked to
yourself you're saying annual income
annual income which city has the most
200 000 earners I have two cities that
come to go for it you want to go first
no God uh well three cities that come to
mind I got New York I've got DC and I've
got San Francisco so it's DC okay and by
the way
and it's not even close okay now do you
know what is the number one sector in DC
that pays that kind of salary lobbyists
lobbyists public administration these
are the types of jobs that they have
downtown by the way do you know what
city in America
is highest in crime today not even close
it's probably DC as well do you know
what city in America
do you know what city in America is the
highest in homelessness per 1000 people
I'm gonna take a wild guess and say DC
do you know what city in America is that
is number one in larceny DC do you know
what city in America is number one in uh
burglary is it DC do you know what city
in number one is in robbery I'll take DC
for 200. do you know do you know what
city I can keep going on and on and on
and on in every possible way DC is
number one and and by the way here's the
crazy stat about DC do you know since
1975 when DC became a district and they
started having Mayors do you know how
many times DC has had a Republican mayor
since 1975. how many times do you think
since 1975. since zero since 1975 that's
50 years how many times do you think one
never never a single Democratic mayor
ever never not maybe once not twice
they've never had it so what does it
tell you terrible policies so people
don't want to move their companies over
there they just don't and by the way you
know what you know what community DC has
been the worst over the years black
community okay horrible if you go a
little lower on this article Rob go a
little lower on this article on by
timmy.com go a little Lord if you look
at the if you look at the numbers go
lower lower lower lower look at that one
right there 1985 the anti-drug Abuse Act
of 1986 they created a law
that was hundred and two hundred to one
crack cocaine disparity which meant that
a person that got caught with crack
cocaine would receive a sentence that
was 100 times longer than a person I got
caught with the same amount of powder
cocaine who do you think they were
targeting African black and by the way
that's 1986 while the mayor is a
Democrat targeting blacks again bad
policies have consequences who in the
right mind is thinking about moving
their families to DC whom the right man
is thinking about moving their families
to San Francisco right now who the right
mind is saying you know what why don't
we move our business to San Francisco I
don't know a lot of people that are
thinking about that stuff the best part
that's going on right now the best part
that's going on right now man we finally
have a few years to look at policies to
say damn that [__] didn't work when
you're in it and people are selling it
you may be like well maybe maybe it does
work let's wait and see if it works
guess what it didn't work San Francisco
failed miserably these see failed
miserably and continues to fill they
don't care about the community what's
going on over there anyways so I love
the fact that what we're looking at
these numbers in the flip side of it Rob
if you want to pull up the least
affordable City can I show you some
numbers about DC real quick
it let me go into this affordable I'll
come back to DC to to flip side of it
here's what happens when you have great
policies okay real estate is booming in
Miami why do you think it is hmm because
people are moving there yeah 900 a day
and it says it's not a good thing not if
you're making under 60 Grand a year and
need some sort of affordable housing
they're right however guess why and what
causes a city to increase pricing in
homes because those types of people are
shown up to your city with the average
income in mind residents would have to
sacrifice 80 of their monthly income to
own such a home la
comes in at a second number two with 77
percent of their income necessary to pay
for purchase home oddly enough Newark
New Jersey is third but that's most
likely due to New York City spillover
yeah it's a post-pandemic New York City
itself is ironically ranked number four
seventy percent needed and then if you
go lower in 2021 62 percent more people
moving to Florida than moved out with
the state's population increasing by two
percent in a single year Miami's tax
rate uh uh with federal tax included are
about 10 lower than that of New York
City resident and a manhattanayi making
150 000 a year saves fifty thousand
dollars just to relocate to Miami okay
by the way Orlando moved up seven spots
just so you know during the same exact
time what does this tell you bad
policies causes you to lose great people
great policies that the same to sat in
Florida causes you to gain great people
very interesting concept and bad
policies attracts bad people and when
people say what do you mean by bad those
who are a net negative to society who
want reparation checks move to San
Francisco those who say I don't need you
to give me any reparation checks just
leave me the hell alone let me build my
life let me raise my kids those people
are moving to places like Florida Texas
Tennessee it's great it's a case study
that's proven which policies attract and
produces results and which policies
attracts and produces trash by the way
Newsom is the case study that's losing
great people gaining net negative people
descent is the case study of gaining
great people losing net negative people
when Dwyane Wade said we can no longer
live in Florida even though it's my home
and a lot of these people have my jersey
on the walls you believe transgenders
should be able to decide to change their
bodies seven eight years old at eight
nine years old yeah you believe that
yeah Florida yeah we we don't think it's
normal California does move over there
no problem do you mean to tell me that's
a net negative to society
um in a way of confusing the hell out of
kids under the age of 18 yes that's an
that negative to society I say yes to
that so anyways you were going to say
some stats about DC uh well yeah just to
kind of give some Credence to you by the
way speaking of that crack epidemic uh
and going on in DC where does Hunter
Biden live these days
who was the only mayor in our country's
history to get arrested oh Marion Barry
Marion Barry the mayor of DC indicted
mayor Hall of Fame he's number one he's
on Mount Rushmore of indicted marriage
yeah he's his campaign thing I will get
the drugs off the street and into my
nose so it's like it was a great
campaign this was the uh uh Rob this is
the the stats on DC I'm sorry of the
highest end go to 2020 census
okay yeah scroll down a little bit by
the way here are the counties where the
median household income we were talking
about look how many counties are in
Virginia now you know they call that
that area around DC the DMV DC Maryland
Virginia with all within you know a half
hour drive of DC let's count how many
are in Virginia DMV area Number One
Loudoun County Virginia number two Falls
Church Virginia then you get three and
four which is California no secret then
you've got Fairfax County we're all
familiar with in Virginia so that's
three out of the top ten then you got
Maryland Howard County Maryland then
you've got Arlington County Virginia
then you have California so
four in the top 10 are all in the
Virginia area so when we find out where
all this lobbyist money goes all these
slush funds go all this waste all this
pork belly they talk about right to
lining the pockets of the people that
work in DC
well and Amazon's uh second headquarters
is now I I I think it's one-third full
now and those are very high paying jobs
he helps and uh we can think AOC for
that being in DC because it could have
been elsewhere so AOC you're so amazing
so great for helping those people but I
actually applaud you for pointing this
out because nobody talks about DC in
this regard we think of San Francisco's
expensive New York's expensive somehow
DC is not exactly in that conversation
but it definitely should be all right so
let's go through some of these uh weird
uh ideas here that that uh just a little
bit craziness here when you take a look
at this stuff
uh student is this a video that we got
or what is it Rob you have the article
here but there's no I have an article up
here for you hang on oh okay because all
I see is the the the story about what's
going on Vivek just tweeted this
uh uh five percent American adults uh
under 30 identify as trans five percent
of adults under 30 identify as trans
five years ago it was point six percent
okay that identified as trans that's not
visibility this is social contagion of a
mental health epidemic okay vivec is
making a lot of sense lately let me do
you want to pull up this tweet Rob to
show this or the audience is this a
tweet you had here was it a video when
he said that it's a tweet and video let
him let him say it play the clip
we need to end this mental health
epidemic not just with anger I'm not
angry at trans people I'm not I'm
frustrated with the culture that
venerates a mental health illness that
we should be treating instead of
actually throwing kerosene on and
fueling to spread like wildfire across
this country I know you're not supposed
to say many of those things out loud but
I just think it's important that we
speak truth because that's got to be the
first step towards getting to a solution
and that's what I'm hoping to deliver
listen too much logic man well he's got
too much logic too many things that make
sense pull up the Tweet one more time I
want to read that one more time for the
audience to see it zoom in a little bit
five percent Americans under the age of
30 identify as trans just five years ago
was only point six percent of 18 to 29
that said they were trans not visibility
this is social contingent of a mental
health epidemic even to the point where
a kid doesn't get a chance to walk
across the stage you saw the story right
this kid is like uh uh you know uh a
student banned from walk-in at
graduation after saying boys or boys and
girls are girls is this the article rap
that you have guys are guys and girls
are girls there is no in between lore
recounted saying I think a lot of people
thought my statement was against people
or uh against people or against groups
and it wasn't targeting any groups at
the time lord was supposed to
in part words of wisdom to younger
students at high school before his
remarks at Shoshone News Press reports
due to the family educational rights and
Privacy Act the school district cannot
go into detail regarding the incident
surrounding lower that makes a lot of
sense of course the student was also
accused of participating a senior prank
involving toilet paper or dead turkey
and Scribe messaging on brick walls
before ceremony they informed me that
they think I'm going to be have an
outburst at graduation I get the senior
prank thing but that was more of a group
thing I haven't had a problem all year I
just think my message was taken the
wrong way so kid cannot say guys or guys
and Pat let's just be honest with
graduate by the way but it's okay Pat we
always talk about wars Russia Ukraine
the war and this the real war is good
and evil and I tell people every single
day I'm like it's wartime like what are
you gonna do are you gonna sit on the
sideline or you're going to get in there
and fight I don't know if you guys saw
this uh Rob I just sent you the link on
uh it's Instagram on slack last week
Calif California passed a b this is a
bill 957 which gives the state the legal
right to deem any parent who doesn't
affirm their child's gender identity as
child abusers and could result in a loss
of custody and then there's the I sent
you this representative if you go to the
video Rob Pat this is uh this is Lori
Wilson saying that she's not only 100
and look what she did with her kid you
listen to that play it play that clip of
her affirming a child gender identity is
in their best interest and it really is
because if you have a seven-year-old
who's who's talking about having a
potential to say I being able to
articulate something they believe that
they are not the same gender as they are
biologically then it should be affirmed
and through care it should be determined
and that's what we did with our own
child and that would give the ability
for a parent who wasn't sure to affirm
and get their child the care that they
need to make that so they can begin to
articulate that determination doing it
but by saying and rejecting it and
wholesale then you're essentially
rejecting your child and that is not in
the best interest of a child we should
be affirming our children in every
possible way and getting them whatever
appropriate care they need whether it's
based on their gender whether it's based
on how their studies are in school it
doesn't matter our children should be
affirmed well so imagine Patrick you
guys heard that her seven-year-old said
either she's a girl opposite sex and
they're like we're all in so that kid I
don't know if it's happened already is
going to get drugs they're going to be
castrated if they're dude like this is
when I'd say it's a freaking war of Good
and Evil those people are making the
laws and making the decisions and if you
pass if your seven-year-old says I want
to be a girl and you have to and you say
no they'll take your kid away that's
what that bill in California is saying
it's unbelievable
well the way I process it is they better
get ready Lord of the Flies in the
classrooms because
first of all
you know affirming your kid hey I want
to have ice cream at 3am if I say no I'm
not affirming my kid you know you you're
basically have to understand that with
kids you need to put guard rails to
create great citizens gay straight
whatever they turn out to be you in
terms of Lifestyle there's guard rails
around entitlement there's guard rails
around structure and behavior and if you
consistently affirm everything then you
have no structure you have you you have
an out of control person that when they
walk into some structure
and let me think like a job they're
going to be ill-equipped to socially in
that environment you know operate when
they walk into some structured
environment like you know a science
class where you can't just say well I I
don't I don't agree that two and two is
four really well I'm not affirming you
I'm giving you a c you know these we are
basically about to raise a generation of
kids that are permanently affirmed and
entitled permanently affirmed in the
wrong ways and are entitled and what we
don't understand is that the structure
builds character and character builds
citizens and citizens build cities
cities built States built countries so
this is this is a very bad waterfall
effect that's that's coming soon Tom
when I was seven years old Pat I swear
to God asked my brother as my sister I
thought it was Superman I would take a
towel wrap it around my neck and run
around the house and did you think these
days you think you're a vampire
well thank God that my mom didn't go you
know what Vinnie you are climb up on top
of our three-story freaking apartment
complex girlfriend and jump because you
could fly thank God she didn't do that a
seven-year-old's mindset I know and I
know people some people are like do you
any of you have kids or I don't have
kids they have kids I don't need kids to
know what's right and what's wrong so if
all those people that are like you don't
have any kids you have no idea it's not
your kid I'm not stupid kids are
innocent and if you don't protect them
then you're on the wrong side can I just
I can't that's an important go go ahead
yeah I'm gonna say this I just want to
be devastated attack the seven year old
I just want to be Devil's advocates for
a second okay well I'll start off by
saying one of the proudest moments I've
ever had in my life was when my 10 year
old nephew was like yeah I have a
girlfriend I'm like that's my dog that's
my guy it's like you never know with a
kid but like all right but here's my
question that that lady giving that
speech right
do you think she loves her kids
I don't know I'm asking
it's not a question of whether you love
your kids you know there are people that
love their pets and they don't train
them and they're a nuisance in the
neighborhood right but you can't compare
a pet to a kid but I'm asking very
simple the hell I can't this isn't this
isn't I got your question I can compare
a person's ability to lead their pets
their dog their fed their family and
their kids and say is this a person of
structure that's respectful of the
neighborhood now kids or humans are fun
and are the ultimate point of value
yeah I can look at somebody and say the
kids are crazy their dog is crazy
they're they're not a good neighbor
they're not helping Society they're not
this is this is nuts gay or straight you
know what do you what are you doing what
I'm solving for is this I'm trying to
understand these parents mindset because
if I I don't have any kids but when I do
and if God forbid I have a
seven-year-old that wants to transition
I'm like not so fast like this this is
not happening like that's not a thing
but these parents who are going to
affirm identities and allow their kids
to take these steroids and hormone
blockers and all this stuff I'm
wondering what how you know how Pat
famously says how do you process this
how do they process like I'm wondering
how they process this I'm assuming they
love their kids and they want the best
for their kids and this is their the
approach that they're taking now I think
it's wrong I think it's weird but I
guess my question is
should they be held responsible for this
should they be held liable for this are
they wrong for doing this I agree that
they should not do this I'm just trying
to understand their mindset as a parent
why they would allow their kids to do
something like that Adam let's ask you
why do you think
I I think I don't know that's why I
generally don't know what do you think
why do you think what causes these guys
to think if these guys love their kids
great so why would they do that I think
that they love their kids so much that
they don't want to tell them no and when
a kid's like I want to be able to put
that as once yeah that's one what else
why else you think I think that there's
some sort of uh societal contagion going
on here and whether perfect so why else
you think two of them so far you said
that one of them is they don't want to
say no to their kids because they think
that's a bad parent number two is
societal contagion which is cool to do
that today so they're kind of following
that why else you think yeah I think um
yeah I I generally this is something
that is is very confusing to me and I
generally don't understand this why
because this was something that didn't
exist when we were kids I didn't know
any kid that was trying to switch
genders I told the store famously about
I knew two girls in in in elementary
middle school that played sports with
all the boys and they were just tomboys
that's it they just they over time they
just became who they were now one is
happily married with kids and one is a
full-on lesbian but she didn't switch
her gender and become a man or anything
on this topic yeah answer your own
question why do you think there's
something going on in society today okay
that's why we do this let's change the
question let's change the question to
this to all of us
so we have to Define is it fair to say
there is
uh bad podcasters out there good
podcasters out there and great
podcasters out there yes okay let's
define the greatest podcaster out there
which is Joe Rogan okay what makes him
the greatest podcaster let's let's give
him the 10 out of 10. okay he's curious
he's funny he's real he's straight up he
has opinions his opinions change he's
evolving he's got some interesting takes
uh he interviews everybody from every
Spectrum everyone anybody and everybody
pretty much for the most part but all
right cool he has the right questions
he's patient he's you know a bunch of
good qualities yeah let's define
although typically no one knows bad
podcasters but let's define what would
make a bad podcast no no preparation no
no research horrible guess no point of
view can't keep my attention you're not
interesting you're you know you're
you're you're not consistent you don't
do it you're just you're not kind of
like something you don't lukewarm about
boom perfect okay so can we go in this
like when we're looking at RFK and we're
comparing him to Peter Hotes in the area
of who has more fancy degrees who wins
hotel in the area of having done more
research in uh health and all that stuff
who wins probably hotels in the area of
who is healthier in life who wins Canada
Kennedy in the area of a person that's
simply asking questions and going
against the establishment who wins
candidate okay you get to pick and
choose on how we Define them all right
let's go here let's define
because this is where the argument ends
let's define a bad parent
and a great parent
what is
a great parent
let's define qualities of a great parent
provides provides for the the child so
it provides gives them the right morals
and the right lessons for life and
guides them God gives them the right
path puts you know puts God in their
life
I think it's someone has structure it's
someone that sets boundaries that
someone that educates that someone that
that shows affection but that that
somebody that isn't afraid to say no you
know now it's changing isn't it there
you go yeah now what's changing isn't it
so you just said it's structure you made
it very eloquent arguments so structure
boundaries somebody that shows no you
said empathy was the third one you said
was very important affection and then
you said what no okay Tom you're a
parent and not you're one of the
greatest parents I know what else would
you add to that well it's something Adam
said a minute ago he said I love you so
much I don't want to say no that's
parental insecurity they love themselves
too much to risk the child great parent
no no great parents I love you too much
to say yes and I'm unafraid of your
reaction because I need to guide you
through it yep I love you too much to
say yes to certain things okay perfect
so now do we want to add anything else
outside of this I thought it was very
smooth how you said a structure
boundaries affection no I love you too
much just say yes do we want to add
anything else here to the great pair I
think you prioritize character and
education I also think it comes down to
roles of a man versus a woman
to the table is different than what Jen
brings to show the table you guys are
different now and you guys are great
parents but the way that you handle
things are different sure can we now
Define what a terrible parent is
someone that's not there okay they're
never there financially they're not
supporting the family security there's
you're not you know I mean they don't
give them a place to live you know what
I mean I'll sum it up is it is that the
purpose of the child is to love them you
know is is a bad parent is the the the
child is there to make you feel better
that's horrible no guidance Pat no
morals we see that everywhere you know
what I mean Pat what else is a quote can
you go up let's just see what Psychology
today say what a terrible parent is what
else would you say about a terrible
parent enablers you know your enablers
you don't correct your child you enable
it and you you mollify it and you give
them a ice cream to shut up whatever
then at the end of the day it's the
exact opposite of what makes a good
parent that you that you don't have
structure you don't have this one you
don't have affections
let's stay there what are signs of bad
parenting look at that strict and rigid
discipline is bad parenting [__]
okay strict and rigid okay
affection and it's little shame okay so
shaming okay I totally get it yeah and
now there's different sides of the
spectrum like on one side little or no
discipline and the other side is rigid
but here's the you got to be amenable
here's the part for this woman to say
hey if your seven-year-old child say
they this you know what you're saying
here's what you're saying what you're
saying is the seven-year-old child
knows just as much as you about life
that's what you just said If the child
says that the child is at an equal level
of wisdom and intelligence as you at 35
years old she looks like she's 35. yeah
is the seven you so then you are dumb
yeah
that's what you are because most
seven-year-olds are trying to learn and
they want Direction and they will say
anything and everything to get attention
now how many videos are you seeing
coming up where the kid says my mom just
wants me to be gay if I become gay my
mom will be so happy and the kids mom
says I never said that your mom you
always want me to be gay I just saw this
I remember that you always say you want
me to be gay honestly I'm not yeah I
can't believe you're saying this online
so so the point is listen somebody has
to have a brass balls to go out there
and say Here's a great parent here's a
bad parent to all the great parents out
there we salute you because you make the
world a safer place
you make communities safer you produce
people like any time like for example
when I would get somebody I said this to
uh uh sheena's mom and dad came and
talked to me one time and I looked at
shino's Mom and Dad and I said listen I
got the product I didn't raise her for
25 for 18 years you did I just want to
tell you thank you because I got
the product after you raised her
look Grace is upstairs yesterday you
know sitting there working doing her
part at 14 15 years old 16 years old
that's a product of Paulette and ciamack
raising her well when I see Bailey by
the way shout out to Bailey she just
took her SAT scores you know what she
got out of 1600 1560. Bailey just got
1560 on her SATs that's too wrong is
that too wrong she just got she got 790
on math she shout out goes to mom and
dad of course it goes to Bailey of
course but Bailey knows if her parents
were somebody else she wouldn't have a
1560. life sometimes you need the right
people in your life to kick your ass and
set an expectation and stand it and say
no Step It Up move up to this level here
that's not easy that's a lot of hard
work and discipline and dedication and
Sacrifice from your own stuff that
you're doing no we have to Define what
is a great parent and what is a bad
parent and we have to keep
recognizing the great parents when I see
I yesterday Mario brought a couple
people here one of the kids was talking
to me hi how are you sir so I love your
work you do the guy is 12 years old I
said why are you so confident he says
what do you mean mom and dad are
standing right I said why do you talk so
eloquently and confidently it's not
normal for a 12 year old to talk like
this well sir I'm a very confident young
man
I said I hope you thank your mom and dad
for raising you this way because this is
not common to this is not common to be
disrespectful discount confident as
you're at 12. I hope when you leave this
place you say thank you to Mom and Dad
because without your mom and that would
you wouldn't be the way you are right
now and I looked at the parents in front
of the kid and I said I salute you I
salute you and I thank both of you for
being great parents we ought to
recognize great parents and we ought to
call out bad parents because it's
happening and these poor seven-year-old
kids eight-year-old kids nine-year-old
kids when they're 38 years old by
themselves and there have no nothing
else to do there is no way of going back
once you take these blockers these
things that you put on your body there's
no way of going back and being the same
person you were being the person that
God created you to be you're questioning
God the concept of saying I am not this
person you're telling God your your
creation wasn't good
this was not a good creation you know
what this is how like I'm having a
conversation with somebody yesterday and
I said look here's what you have to
realize
I don't sit there and you know you know
certain things that were wired we
improve as human beings but certain
things you're wired the way you are yeah
okay but some of the stuff it's like an
excuse to say now wow that's just kind
of how I am it is what it is I'm a
smoker it is what it is I don't work out
it is what it is no
if he created somebody that says overly
you know high standards you know busting
their ass very detailed meticulous OCD
whatever all this stuff that people want
to add up there but if you're somebody
that's a high standard person who
created you that way
probably a byproduct your parents God
you're wiring your DNA that's how you
create it phenomenal thank you for
building me that way but today today
when it comes down to parents man I wish
we would do a better job recognizing
these great parents you know the whole
thing that we're trying to do with
Glendale
whole thing that we're trying to do with
Glendale right now and we're talking to
a bunch of hosts to all the people that
are listening that you guys are having
calls late night all this stuff I get
all the messages just so you know you
know who you are I want to tell you I
thank you I applaud you I respect you
we're trying to get a hold right now all
these halls in Glendale every one of
them have been uh have been very uh what
do you call it accommodating all of them
such a freaking classy just the
community show we want to do but they're
like Pat we got weddings on Friday and
Saturday nights they're right I mean no
stop the wedding no you got to do your
weddings I totally get it we're trying
to do something to go Glendale do an
event I don't know if it's going to
happen anytime I wanted to do this
Thursday this Friday or Saturday because
I want to do in a momentum Psy
we're leaving right but
the only reason I want to go to Glendale
is just to tell the great parents listen
don't second guess yourself you're doing
good
keep doing and raising your standards we
ain't perfect but keep getting better
they just need a platform for people to
realize you are incredible as a parent
keep raising the standards they're
making you think you're making a mistake
but you're not you're doing a good job
so this whole conversation can be solved
if we can identify what's a great parent
and what's a bad one we recognize the
great ones and we call out the bad ones
until we do that this is going to
continue yep and you have to abandon I
think when you see it like I said about
the Battle are they going to send the
sideline or you're going to step up it's
those same parents and we've been seeing
it this entire month yes it's been pride
month and I congratulate all the people
for all my gay friends and family
members with the pride but these are the
same bad parents that are taking their
children three years old four years old
two years old and then bringing them in
the street Pat when there's grown men
butt naked butt naked twerking there was
something I think in Minneapolis one in
New York where there was like a fox
Seattle there's a fountain Tom of water
and it was just no clothing was optional
people did like listen to me if you are
a parent and you are bringing your kids
front row to a parade where there is
butt naked grown ass man you fall in
that shitty horrible bad parent and you
should be ashamed of yourself and I wish
there was a law that where you're asked
to get arrested for doing that [__]
because because Tom at five years old I
remember everything I remember
everything visual this is going to be
stuck in little kids heads for the rest
of their lives and I think this is it's
disgusting and they should be ashamed
I'm with you Vinnie this is absolutely
absurd this is ridiculous if you're
listen if you're an adult you want to go
to something like this and see naked
sloppy people walk around and celebrate
the pride stuff all you but if you bring
your child to this I would say that is
on the realm of child abuse and I'll say
one thing and Pat I want to get your
opinion on this
you got pride month that's 30 days pride
month there's all there's also trans
awareness day and there's all there's so
many different
lgbtq things going on there to celebrate
the pride month
you've got one day of Mother's Day
and you've got one day of Father's Day
what's the month that they celebrate
families what month is that
it doesn't exist I was just like what
okay
why are we recognizing we're we're
capitulating to the one percent or the
two percent of the three percent are
great you have your rights but family
values we've seen them plummet in the
last decade or two right since the 80s
basically and I think what what you're
saying is that Common Sense always wins
and Common Sense prevails what we're
trying to I think see is this return to
normalcy is like families are what make
up America not naked gay dudes parading
in a street and I think people are just
over it by the way this guy Brian
cressenstein I don't I don't know who he
is but he's he's somebody because he's
got a big following on Twitter uh he
said number one seen a man naked on a
bike isn't going to have much of an
impact on any kids they have likely seen
their fathers or brothers naked before
okay there's a big difference between
your father when you're four years old
versus a random dude you have number two
by the way Elon Musk tweeted this number
two sharing an uncensored video of a
naked man on a bike to an audience or
possibly 30 million kids on Twitter is
arguably worse than riding a bike naked
in front of a kid or two and planned
event that the kids took them to says
number three there are much worse things
than the average kid will see or hear
online and offline in a typical week by
the way you realize this guy saying what
he's saying seeing a man naked on a bike
isn't going to have much of an impact on
any kid
either this guy doesn't have kids or two
if he does he doesn't value that part uh
but I will tell you majority of America
majority
fully disagrees with you on this Brian
and I think I would put that as 95
percent parents not people that are
single not people that don't have kids
this would need to be a very clear poll
with parent parents with kids would
totally disagree with this but this gets
people to say well he's right what's the
big deal what's the big deal yeah this
is when you have to call out [__]
and you have to call out what's people
that are doing it right so he starts
with a justification moves on to being
an apologist and then finishes with the
justification so he really doesn't make
a point of his own here
at all yeah but you know what some
people follow it and they say that makes
a lot of sense elamas retweeted and said
this guy makes no sense anyone's got I
don't know 10 kids I think at this time
and one of those kids
went trans I believe yep one of his kids
I mean one of the ten the odds I mean
you know it is it is listen when there
is a divorce and the father's not not
there on a daily basis some mothers will
raise their kids I got a few friends
right now that uh you know the biggest
fear of a father is when there's a
divorce
is who is going to have that influence
over their kids when the girl dates
somebody else that was my dad's biggest
fear okay to see what man is going to
have influence over me if my mother was
to get remarried now my parents neither
one of them got remarried my mother
didn't get remarried my dad didn't get
remarried I I was that second time they
remarried each other
yeah that's a good point and they both
swore off in that yeah but it's a fear
because you're kind of like that's my
kid what's he gonna feed him what's he
gonna tell him what's he gonna do this
what's he gonna do that so completely
when you lose your kid to mother and
they're they're doing what they're doing
there's a risk of seeing how that
woman's gonna raise him I encourage
everybody
um to go back and find the Bill Maher
speech this is now about uh not speech
it was a um a position statement that he
made leading into the debate that he has
on his show and four months ago he did
it and he starts out with the statistics
on the percent of population that was
gay and then he moves on to things but
he makes it really important point he
says with kids everything is phases and
I when I was young I wanted to be a
pirate when he was like seven eight
years old I am so glad my parents didn't
send me out for eye removal and peg leg
surgery so he's making a great point
about all that about phases and he makes
another point and he says I find it a
little odd that I go to these parties in
Los Angeles and angelinos are there and
it's somehow fashionable to have a trans
kid and to trade stories of how you're
working through it so it's about a seven
minute uh monologue that he does but he
makes a bunch of Common Sense points and
I think there's a wave of common sense
that's coming and there's a lot of
people that are bringing Common Sense
forward like the Glendale in Glendale
The Armenian Community my hats off to
you you were not only bringing common
sense you had people sitting there at
city council that made comments about
the genocide but common sense is coming
to the fore and in that moment you have
have a practical presentation by Bill
Maher in front of the camera and then
you have people saying I've had enough
and I'll see you at City Hall and I'll
see you at the school at the Armenian
community at the Glendale Unified School
District so I think we're going to see
more of both of Common Sense calm and
you're also going to see more parents
stepping up because I I think in terms
of this wokeness the majority of America
has had enough and I think these things
let them know hey you know what it's
okay to protest it's okay to go out
there and make your point look what
these people did at Glendale Unified
School best the best and by the way they
weren't the ones wearing masks and
fatigue no no the antifa the the you
know the antifa that we're Milling
around in the crowd there were the
people there were very straight up you
see these rational things why do you not
like this flag why do you not like this
flag trying to engage in in in in in
common debate and I love that I think
there's a wave of of let me tell you
woke is going to be met by awake and
awake you awaken the giant which is
common sense and I just hope this this
giant Club common sense is big enough
yeah what I said earlier Tom about the
people that are on the sideline or the
people that fight in the war Armenians
are the ones that are going to step up
and fibro antifa's biggest mistakes been
going crazy for how many years going to
cities terrorizing people they showed up
at the wrong place and got their asses
Armenian mothers grandmothers beating
the [__] out of dorky ass antifa little
white guy I was that was one of the
dopest moments shoved and provoked
but mind you though their front lines
they're Warriors bro it's for kids it's
not like they're just out there to start
start trouble but that's yo antifa went
to the wrong place and I bet guarantee
you they will never go to Glendale
California to start [__] again period
done deal end of story I'd like to know
in the middle of Highly Muslim
Minneapolis you know there's one side of
Minneapolis that is incredibly Muslim a
lot of somalis up there yeah I call it a
mini
um
what's the capital of uh Somalia
Mogadishu yeah they call it many a
little Mogadishu exactly I'll be there
this weekend by the way I'd like to know
how well the if they had a pride pray I
don't know did they have a pride parade
in Downtown Minneapolis and how did that
go with the Muslim Community I'll check
that out for you it's actually a very
good question you're asking I'm sure uh
you know Adam's going to do some legwork
to find out CNN could be put up for sale
CNA could be put up for sale and bought
by ousted CEO Jeff Zucker Daily Mail
story that just came out here let's see
what happens here with Jeff sucker Jeff
Zucker behind CNN that would be a power
play what about there Trump buying it
they will not let oh my God Trump so CNN
parent company Warner Brothers
discoveries considering selling the
network announced that SEO job soccer
has emerged as a potential buyer aiming
to regain control and see climb uh
ultimate revenge for his firing Warner
Brothers Discovery CEO David zaslav's
future plans for CNN are unclear with
options including a potential merger
with CBS or sale of the network
suggesting preparation for possible
sales CNN as face Financial challenges
earning 500 million dollars lesson
profits last year controversial
incidents including disastrous town hall
with Donald Trump and the departure
long-time anchor Don Lemon has
contributed to the Network's decline Tom
what do you have uh what thoughts you
got on this year so
first of all
um
this is not conspiracy this is real
the people that were speaking up inside
CNN when Chris slick remember a couple
weeks ago he um you know entered into
retirement
um uh suddenly
they were the Zucker people left over
after Zucker left
so the remnant of Zucker became Rebels
that were working to undermine Chris
elect and then Chris elect undermined
himself with some very bad business
decisions it didn't go particularly well
and so now you've got Zucker back saying
hey I want to buy this well he's going
to be buying low because we are seeing
what's going to add sales numbers and
things like that and you have David
zazlov who is like how do I get out of
this thing this is like this is like a
damaged brand because you look at all
the things that's happened you had the
Cuomo situation then you had the Zucker
situation then you had a Don Lemon
situation and now you've got Chris
Slick's situation so if you're zazzlev
Warner Brothers Discovery who has a lot
of debt on the books Pat when you bought
this thing maybe you just sell this
particular house and the reason they
mentioned CBS we'll go quick case study
NBC doesn't need it they have CNBC MSNBC
they have a diversity that goes from the
mainstream Flagship all the way down
into the cable Nets and ABC well they're
trying to make a profit it out of ESPN
they're not in the buy-in mode they're
in the consolidation under Disney kind
of selling and trying to trim it up mode
which leaves CBS hey you really don't
have a uh you know a cable net out there
maybe you take CNN and turned it to CBS
CNN or something so I I think that CNN
is in a tough straight but I think it's
pretty freaking ironic that Zucker comes
back with the private Equity Firm where
he's at now talking about buying it
after his fingerprints he was behind the
scenes bitter about being tossed out
after his own malfeasance and watching
zazlov then fire Chris Licht and it was
some of the zucker's own people that
were in there like Rebels helping Chris
lich's mistakes be even greater
Amplified I think it's pretty ironic
that Zucker wants to make a run at this
you want to talk about ironic you saw
Don lemon's first interview since he got
fired he said I send you the link Rob on
on slack he said uh his commitment to
the truth is what he's talking about and
he said saying uh he believes he doesn't
believe in platforming liars and bigots
how how is somebody like that that has
been peddling lies for CNN have the gall
to say did you hear this Matt Adam um
Rob can you play that
this is his first he's talking about
sucker no he's talking about just his
his his responsibility to tell the truth
and how they're giving them people
platforms for liars and bigots what's
the date Vinnies does this just happen
okay or perfect union not a perfect
union I'm not a perfect person no one is
but I think the Constitution deserves us
um to we we in order to fulfill uh the
promise of the Constitution we have to
stand up for what is right
say anything there didn't say anything
there this guy I I don't I don't know if
he is actually that big of a deal when
it comes down to people taking his word
he was never a top 10 show ever never
there's always a top 50 top 100 show but
he's just famous I think Don Lemon is
known from being famous and went to the
right school and worked at the company
called CNN it's all he is nothing more
nothing less nothing
if you talk Chris Cuomo he had influence
you know if you talk uh uh he's not
moving no he's not nobody wakes up and
let me see what Don Lemon has to say
about who I should vote for no one said
that they said that by Chris Cuomo no
question not Don Lemon
not the element they're not the same
league so let's go to the next story
here about Legacy Media companies enter
dark times after failures Mount and
Netflix rises again
um let me see here let's see okay so
Lexi media companies have struggled
throughout the first half of 2023 with
Disney laying off 7 000 employees its
largest Pixar movie underperforming
while Warner Brothers discoveries also
reducing its Workforce and dealing with
internal issues it's been a bumpy ride
for Disney Warner Brothers Disney is
laying off more uh employees it just
keeps getting worse uh and eternal said
that rich Greenfield a light shed
um media analyst said that media
meanwhile Netflix thrives with investors
excited by the potential of new signups
as it cracks down on password sharing
and is predicted to benefit from ongoing
Hollywood work shutdowns investors have
once again become excited by Netflix's
future prospects The Beneficial of
Hollywood work shutdowns will likely be
Netflix despite the possibility of
reprieve of Legacy Media due to
potential advertising gains in the 2024
U.S presidential campaign the future
looks bleak due to a lack of growth
narrative and hurdles and consolidation
there's uh currently no strong growth
narrative narrative for Legacy Media and
consolidation prospects are murky Tom
what's going on over here well let's
start with that last sentence the the
currently no strong growth narrative
guess what all the households that could
possibly have cable have cable and it's
running in Reverse so one of the ways
you make money as a Legacy Media company
is called Carriage fees Carriage fees
are all of us that have cable and we pay
60 bucks to somebody a little piece of
that goes to ESPN it doesn't need a
little piece that goes CNN that's called
The Carriage fee so Carriage fees have
peaked and coming down which means that
you got to go online you have to have a
Hulu an Ott solution well you know the
peacocks out there not doing as well as
expected Hulu's gone out there oh wait
it peaked now it's uh we've heard it's
shedding subscribers and then Netflix
the reason they're up again is because
they crack down on sharing passwords and
guess what happened they got a bunch of
subscribers you know why because it was
just 15 bucks and you know why the
people with the subscriber let's say I
was letting you borrow it because you're
my brother yeah right and we live in the
same house and I put on your laptops
wherever you are you can watch it
technically that's password sharing now
they've cracked down do I cancel Netflix
no I just say Amen Vinnie sorry you
can't use it anymore yeah well I've been
using it for so long it's only 15 bucks
I'll pay for it that is what's happening
at Netflix so Netflix has growth to add
subscribers where the legacies don't
have a place to add subscribers and what
they're talking about consolidation Pat
they're talking about when Warner
Brothers Discovery Consolidated and then
when Disney has ESPN ABC and all the
things they've bought and they
Consolidated consolidation is power
that's how Hulu was able to charge us
all because it was Consolidated
ownership of all those channels so right
now Netflix is coming up again they're
adding subscribers thanks to the
password thing now that's only for a
season a year or two from now that's
going to run its course and it's going
to be back where my new subscribers but
um and by the way all the Legacy Media
it's interesting what they say they are
praying that would please please please
can we get to January 15th of 24 for the
first primary so that we can get ad
revenues going on our news channels
they're dying for the election but
that's what's going on it's it's it's
not a fun place to be right now if
you're an owner of a media company to
give you some uh number in the Legacy
Legacy but I'll give you some numbers
and there are New Media companies coming
and new Ott's coming changes on the
horizon and I'll just make something up
here the future looks bright yeah there
you go let me give you some numbers Tom
just I just looked at Netflix uh stock
ticker and um November 2021 height of
covid their stock peaked at 682 dollars
right that's the highest it's ever been
six months later seven months later June
of 2022 it cratered down to 190 in the
last year or so it's now up to 4 15.
when it hit 190 in June of 22 I know
you've done case studies on this that
was the lowest it's been since 2017. so
it's had these ups and downs since
pre-covered post-covered but it seems
like they're back on the right track
right now yeah well the peak for 682
remember there was an artificial surge
that was in viewership and there service
because everybody was at home forced to
be home yeah you know you know
legislated to be at home we can go back
to there again and then When the Smoke
Clears on that you know the post covet
hangover hit for everybody in the market
and so they they're they're stock going
down to 190 was also part of a momentum
shift that happened in the market flunk
and then everything comes back and
they're back at you know 450. you know
what's funny look at Tesla Tesla was
what 110 at the beginning of the year
and now they're up at 240. you know
what's funny about Netflix it's almost
like the inverse situation of what
happened with the stock market we all
remember there was a stock market crash
it went down 30 40 on whatever the
number was
exact opposite thing happened with
Netflix Skyrocket boom covet ends or six
months later uh stock market comes back
Netflix crashes you know the tech
companies and now it's sort of leveling
out to where it should be that's a great
Point
um Malik if you could put up the zoom
chart oh man probably oh yeah exactly
same with zoom same exactly your your
point skyrocketed and then fell cratered
yeah just stay right here and just go
find Zoom
yep
and you just go back like five years
there you go
except that Zoom is not coming back the
Creator as much though well oh no it has
it tailed out in 2022 yeah you're
absolutely right it just wasn't a sharp
drop like Netflix right now Netflix is
coming back because there's something to
come back on whereas there's not much
something to come back so what do you
think the future of Zoom is at this
point does it need another pandemic in
order to reach the heights that it was I
mean honestly I think Zoom probably
needs a check from somebody that wants
to consolidate yeah gotcha they should
have sold in 20 in 2020. right when they
peaked like like two men what if what if
it's like two of them what if Google
what if Google buys zoom and puts it
into Google Docs into Google Suite right
Microsoft you know tried this already
and they already remember they bought
the first zoom zoom 1.0 is that teams
Skype Microsoft teams oh gotcha but now
they have teams yeah Microsoft yeah the
technology and teams and it's so so
let's do the last story here on wrap up
Vinnie I'm coming to you with this one
here new court documents reveals more
about Epstein's relationship with
JPMorgan Chase
reveal a deeper relationship between
Jeffrey Epson and JP Morgan Chase with
prosecutors uh filing exhibits
containing hundreds of new emails the
bank accused of facilitating Epstein's
child sex trafficking operation
and has been criticized for slow
document uh production the involvement
of JPMorgan CEO Jamie Diamond Ramis a
central remains a central question while
an email implicates him in approving a
120 million dollar transfer the bank
claims Diamond was unaware of Epstein as
a client Epstein has direct contact with
multiple Bank employees including Jess
Staley the head of the wealth and later
Investment Banking divisions who
received business advice and connections
Gucci Staley allegedly supplied Epstein
with confidential information and favors
in exchange for Bank turning a blind eye
to his sex trafficking convictions
dailies association with Epson led to
his resignation as Barclay CEO Vinnie
what do we know about it's like it's
like right just when you think that I've
seen stuff is like dying out or
something's like gonna stop it's like it
keeps coming it's like a it's the
Epstein Saga anything that has to do
with covering up this pedophilia ring it
it's happening like like when he when he
got suicide in jail it's like a bad
murder mystery the cameras were off
people weren't looking the driver did
this by the way JP Morgan and Jeffrey
Epstein emails were released and now Pat
this was a couple days ago they
mistakenly JP Morgan mistakenly deleted
47 emails the security Exchange
Commission find Chase only four million
dollars how convenient all the business
records which are supposed to hold for
three years under the SEC rules were
deleted data from January 1st to April
23 2018. they were deleted in June 2019
from uh 8 700 mailboxes uh including
those belonging to as many 7 500
employees and it's like Pat and then a
random I swear to you I was telling Rob
this I was waiting for somebody to
either accidentally pass away or
something like that Jim Crown who's a
board member of JP Morgan Chase died on
Sunday in a random plane crash and let's
not forget Pat they just paid Chase
290 million dollars for all these all
the situations with everything with the
uh where was that Rob where the island
and all that situation let's it's it's
hush money they were hoping that that
money would have everybody shut up but
it's and again going back to the the
they're in on it Chase bank is in on all
this [__] with Epstein and now what they
just they're being accused they're being
accusable Pat they're paying these
little fun 200 million dollars is
nothing to Chase bank and then again
we're accidentally you miss as well this
is 290 million dollars seller lawsuit
alleging it knowingly uh benefited from
direct line Jeffrey UPS is sex
trafficking according to a court filing
Tuesday lawyers of Epstein's victims
filed a notice of settlement in
Manhattan saying the deal has approved
the deal and so on the tournament will
go to a class of women who claim to have
been victims of Epstein as much as 30
set aside for their lawyers according to
defiling so 70 went to the women wow and
again this is hush money Vinnie let me
type I don't know man I don't know if
people think that banks are willing to
turn a blind eye to this type of stuff
and and throw their morals out the
window for money okay I don't know if
banks these days are willing to put
profits ahead of people I don't know if
banks are willing to do that there's
been no indications that Banks like this
like Deutsche Bank or Wells Fargo yeah
or any of these banks are willing to
basically throw all their moral
convictions out the window for a blank
check Vinnie I'm not I'm not sure what
we're going with it am I right I don't
think that these Banks would ever ever
do something unscrupulous like oh we've
had the big short now we have the big
screws
the movie's coming yeah it's just and
again we talked about this for how many
weeks about accountability they're not
dude 290 million is nothing this whole
situation with kids and again I'm going
back to that the war the the war of good
and evil evil is just it's just kicking
out
follow the money brother there's got to
do some money laundering and washing it
around and if some of the Epstein people
are willing to basically whitewash 300
million dollars whatever the number is
they'll be a bank willing to do that I
guarantee you that well I'm with Chase
and I'm going to be leaving Chase very
shortly no I think what you also see
here what was it 40 million dollars was
the supplemental fine for the no four
four million for for deleting 47 million
emails mistakenly somebody said what you
know how that works it goes like this
you're my attorney yeah hey Vinnie yep
if um
this is kind of weird so if these if
these emails get out what's the penalty
well they already they already did 290
million dollars could be another couple
hundred million dollars yeah but what's
up what's a fine from this FEC for
basically four million ish not not too
crazy why okay well let's just uh okay
we'll just add that to the cost of the
suit and uh let's uh let's do what we
gotta do okay so just pull the trigger
happens every day and whether and by the
way it's sad but this is part of the
corruption and the two levels of justice
that we have in this country you know
the wealthier are able to make these
decisions hide behind it stall the suit
all these things like this and evidence
is you know uh withheld destroyed and
things like this
um sorry to be a downer but let's just
talk about what the reality is and to
your point that you made very loud and
sarcastically you're absolutely right
they're like
you know what kind of business are you
in well I do this and this and I do this
and this anybody knows the story of
Pablo Escobar they know there was two
Regional Miami Banks and basically the
Central Bank of Panama that were turning
a blind eye to Pablo Escobar because
they had massive deposits that the bank
took in Miami massive deposits and then
they they were loaning those out as home
loans and car loans and had a very fine
little business because you need what
assets to make loans yeah so it's no
secret it's a dirty little secret down
here in Miami that Miami was basically
built on the cocaine uh smuggling you
wouldn't say you wouldn't say you know
okay gang uh but we're coming to the end
of the podcast we got this Thursday uh
we're flying somebody out that's going
to be out here to talk about the ins and
outs of what's going on in Russia and
Ukraine and this guy is the expert to do
so so I can't wait for this Thursday's
podcast stay tuned for that but at the
same time Fourth of July is around the
corner and we have our military merch
drop that we're about to do the new
future looks right hats that are here
with two options for you with the black
or the white and the future looks bright
here Tom uh and then sick
are you trying to like do a military
over it from the halls of mine so we got
this here and we got a bunch of other
things that's going to be out there for
the drop so for those of you guys that
want to participate in this text award
merch to
310-340-1132 text the word merch to
three one zero three four zero one one
three two we will see you guys on
Thursday take care everybody bye-bye